millie is a pro on screen but behind the
scenes she's usually a total goofball
that combined with the complex scenes to
shoot makes for a whole lot of bloopers
so let's dive into those not so polished
millie moments on set
number one in a roller rink no one is
safe do you come here a lot yeah
will does not no but i go to parties
here roller skates may be making a bit
of a comeback but millie hasn't quite
got the hang of it yet the actress may
have been rolling out of control but at
least she could always laugh about it
let's hope no one in the cast was left
with too many bruises afterwards
didn't you see the sign dummy
no food or drinks on the rink
number two they love each other they
punch each other
millie bobby brown had her work cut out
for her facing off with the helena
bonham carter though they belittle they
are fierce
except when they slip up millie
certainly brought the heat even if she
didn't mean to at times helena bottom
carter didn't know what hit her
and she's much better than me and
number three who knew one hat could
cause so much distraction when you're in
the moment on set the silliest slip up
can ruin a take but it definitely didn't
mess with those good vibes but hey when
you're in a high stress level scene like
that you've gotta be able to laugh about
it
number four
sometimes the smallest thing is a
distraction
a cough that's all it took to cause the
actors to lose focus on the godzilla vs
kong set the fact that millie is the
first to crack isn't too surprising
since being on this movie set was like
being right at home we wonder which day
of filming they were on for this scene
number five she wound up having to say
it multiple times
i'm sorry
i'm sorry
that dummy wasn't so safe in millie's
hands it seems but to be fair it's
almost bigger than she is the stranger
thinks props are great to work with but
only when you can actually manage them
number six you never know which
locations will bring risk
let's go
good luck
though to be fair we doubt anyone
thought millie would be in any kind of
danger just walking down the hill but it
does seem like they were trying to make
a quick escape clearly too quickly
number seven
nice hat
a blooper is really just a reason to
throw in a cheeky line right millie grew
up in front of the cameras so you know
she'll always make the most of a moment
on screen that was cool honestly we
would have loved to see this one make
the cat shall we cut
number eight the truth isn't always what
you want to hear
[Music]
improvising on set is pretty typical for
millie but sometimes she could go a bit
off the rails letting co-stars know what
was what and asking the questions we all
want answers to like
what's the stash about number nine
millie really messed up this one this
scene seemed to be smooth sailing that
is until the moment she cracked and then
she even drew all the attention away
from the action but that wasn't the only
time she ruined a take on this scent
[Music]
number 10 you never know what you're
gonna get when she's on set slaps is a
game that has been known to make its way
onto sets early harry potter days anyone
but the slaps that millie goes for on
set well it's not quite what we're used
to
where does she get her energy this
actress was always on guard and ready to
throw some feisty hits no matter who her
co-star was no one is safe
you've progressed nicely i can see
number 11 well this one wound up being a
bit more silly than serious dark and
broody setting intense fight seems like
a recipe for a moody and serious scene
but that didn't mean it couldn't turn on
a dime milly could cause some serious
damage
number 12 this kind has nothing to do
with dental hygiene i mean i can do it
abnormally fast
it's quite cool no matter the day no
matter the costume nothing was gonna
stop milly from busting out those moves
on the anola home set somehow she
cracked the code to flossing and
restrictive costumes
do you trust me
number 13.
step aside there is a new spice girl in
town
how adorable is teeny tiny millie on the
set of the tv show intruders even in her
early days she brought the party to set
and some pretty good dance moves
that pout though
oh my god it was the funniest thing
number 14.
nothing marks a friendship like a
handshake let's do it this isn't just
any handshake though this is one that
became a regular occurrence for millie
and julian dennison on the godzilla vs
kong set it even comes with a whole
script that seems to be setting quite
the scene would we expect anything less
from the queen of the screen millie
herself godzilla
number 15. you never know who'll be
right around the corner michael jordy
has made me a paranoid person you guys
it became somewhat of a regular thing on
the godzilla set for actors and crew
members to surprise millie in any way
they could and from what we can tell she
got real shook did you see this though
i'm like so scared number 16
millie knows what she wants
i don't what this is a flowery absolute
moral
no chance she was going to settle for
less than she deserves even though she
looks poshes can be as sherlock's
younger sister millie wasn't going to be
polite in letting this misstep slide
they were quite beautiful i don't even
think about flowers of course
number 17. she hasn't been in a public
school for a while and it shows she knew
there wasn't a chance she could cover up
this stumble i don't get that one
so how many takes are we guessing this
one took
what
yes
[Music]
her co-star should have been setting a
good example we spent our time
just goofing off on satin even at 13
milli was bonding with her adult
co-stars and bringing the fun to the
godzilla king of monster set though it
did mean she had to defend herself from
co-star vira farmiga she's a goofball of
the highest order but it seems the rest
of the crew weren't safe from the milly
monster she's a she's a little rascal
number 19
so many lines so many takes
wow i think letting them be who they
want to be she's a seasoned actor now
but filming a video for unicef was
tricky for millie who was flubbing time
after time but you gotta love her
persistence
november 20th
number 20 we can't forget to include
this gem
together remember when sadie sink and
millie made our days with their original
musical these kind of antics meant it
was just another day on set full of
young and talented kids i can
do it it seems like whenever millie
bobby brown is on set it's a total party
like i was so frightened you know
because it's just like these seasoned
actors and i'm just like a little baby
working with people who become like
family tends to lead to comfortable
environments where all these shenanigans
can happen
let me think
do you have any ideas the fact that she
started acting when she was so young led
to a totally different level of
confidence on set and we are here for it
which was your favorite slip up on set